It's easy to feel that the way we experience life is generally the same for others,
but did you realize that the majority of people in this world that don't actually have the internet?
About 3.5 billion people - or only 40% of the world - has an internet connection today,
meaning, this digital reality we experience is actually done so by a minority of people in the world!
Or how about the fact that the majority of people in the world live in this circle?
In fact it contains 22 of the world's 37 megacities which each have at least 10 million people.
Only two cities in America fall into this category: New York and Los Angeles.
On that note, the majority of the world actually live in "Developing Countries."
In fact, modern language is now advocating to change terms like "Third World Country" to
"Majority World Country" to more accurately represent that these countries are well...
...the majority of humankind!
Even if the G8 countries make decisions that affect the majority of people on this planet.
To that point around 70%-80% percent of people on this planet make less than $10 US dollars a day!
While even in a wealthy country like America, over 50% percent of people make less than $30,000 dollars a year!
The good news, is that global poverty has fallen by half over the last decade.
But we still have a global environment where more people have cellphones than toilets!
And when they're talking on those phone, the vast majority aren't speaking English as a first language.
The majority also aren't Christian.
As of November 2016, most people are male, with roughly 55 million less females on the planet!
And of our population, the majority are under the age of 30!
In America, once you turn 37, you're officially older than half the country!
And the most common age for a person to be worldwide?
0 years old, followed by 1 year old, 2 years old, 3, 4, and then...26 years old?
The majority of adults in the world weigh around 61 kilograms or 135 pounds.
Whereas the vast majority of people in North America are overweight! :(
And while the majority of North Americans drink coffee over tea,
3 cups of tea are drank for every 1 cup of coffee worldwide, making it a much more popular drink!
Speaking of North America, the majority of the Canadian population actually lives south of Seattle!
In terms of energy consumption,
the vast majority of the world consume more than 2x times less energy per capita than Canadians or Americans
If we take a wide view,
it turns out that the majority of the universe is made up of Dark Energy at 68%, Dark matter makes up 27%,
and the rest
- everything on Earth and everything ever observed with instruments, otherwise called "Normal Matter" -
only makes up 5% of the universe!
And given that atoms are made up of 99.99% empty space,
the majority of you is...nothing! ;)
We want to send a special thanks to Bill and Melinda gates for supporting this episode
Did you know the number of childhood deaths have been cut in half over the last 15 years and that?
122 million children's lives have been saved since 1990 sometimes it may feel like the world is getting worse
But global health intervention is changing that and in their annual letter Bill and Melinda gates highlight this amazing progress
But also the challenges like how 45 percent of child deaths are linked to malnutrition
[you] can check out the annual letter at gates letter Com by using the link in the description below to learn about and support their
Amazing initiative don't forget to subscribe for more weekly science videos every Thursday